تركيا لن تتخلى عن استكمال الحزام الامني
الذي تعتزم تنفيذه على حدودها مع سوريا
رغم التحذيرات الامريكيه وامكانيه اندلاع
مواجهه مباشره واسعه مع القوه الكرديه في
الشمال السوري
حزام يمتد على طول الحدود مع سوريا بعمق
30 كلم وتهدف انقره من خلاله لتامين
حدودها من الهجمات الارهابيه وايضا طرد
المجموعه الكرديه من الشمال السوري
الاتراك الا انا واشنطن حذرت انقره من
مغبه تعطيل عمليه القوات الامريكيه
والكرديه ضد تنظيم داعش في سوريا
ليست هناك خصومه دائمه في السياسه هذا ما
اكده الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان عندما
تطرق الى علاقه بلاده مع سوريا في الوقت
الذي تسع موسكو لترتيب لقاء بين اردوغان
والرئيس السوري بشار الاسد الذي رفض
اللقاء ما لم تنسحب القوات التركيه بشكل
كامل من الاراضي السوريه
على الارض ازدادت التحركات العسكريه حيث
سيره القوات الامريكيه دوريات المشتركه مع
قوات الاسد واشرت قوات التحالف تدريبات في
قاعدتها بحقل كونغو كما وصلت تعزيزات
كرديه من 600 جندي باليات ومدافع ودبابات
الى ريف حلب
مؤشرات على ان الوضع متجه نحو مواجهه
عسكريه قريبه
انس نماسي العربيه